one defensive player has been named mvp
in a miami super bowl who is that jake
scott that is incorrect scott was the uh
super bowl mvp in los angeles uh you
don't have a facts and figures book
because only me and mike florio have one
all right well let's see if you can go
out there maybe you can read it online
like the rest of you peons do
[Music]
that's funny you know for a while chris
mad dog russo uh claimed he was the only
one who had a copy of the nfl record and
factbook it's getting harder and harder
to find because they don't sell it
anymore you've got to say the magic
words you've got to have the special
password the secret handshake to get one
i've got one going back 20 years i got
another one this year and peter you've
got one too you're in the club there are
very few of us that have a hard copy of
the nfl record and factbook so take that
mad dog we got one out all right uh
peter do you know the answer to the
question you're allowed to consult the
record fact book defensive player
there you go
they're they're i mean they they've
never won them you you've got to you've
got to know it's chuck howley jake scott
right i mean come on
and also chuck alvin and also
larry brown larry brown right and chuck
hallie the only
player from the losing team to win the
super bowl mvp also a native of my
hometown in northern west virginia
played for the warwood vikings back in
whatever year it would have been before
he played in the nfl but chuck halley
the game that was decided by the late
field goal jim o'brien kicks the field
goal to win it for the colts back before
the super bowl really became a thing
that would have been a big deal right a
walk-off field goal to win a super bowl
and it was kind of like no big deal at
the time it'd be a much bigger deal
today obviously all right time for to oh
oh you win you got the trivia question
right so you get to go first in today's
draft moves that got san francisco and
kansas city to the super bowl anything
you want it to be wide open transactions
coaching decisions anything you want it
to be go
picking george kittle in the fifth round
by the san francisco 49ers in 2017
in my opinion is the single biggest you
know draft acquisition of either team
uh you know obviously other than patrick
mahomes
uh and and i picked this one mike
because obviously i don't mean to be
whatever but i mean there's some very
obvious ones but this one for value
and for what the 49ers paid for it a
third day draft choice and they got the
best tight end in football sorry travis
kelsey i like kittle just a little bit
more
but they got the best guy at his
position and the value of this pick just
screams out to me
yeah you know it's funny as you started
down that path and thinking wait a
minute what about patrick mahomes we got
to go patrick mahomes because it was
2017 and there was only a select handful
of people in the nfl
who knew that mahomes was a generational
talent and they kept their mouths shut
and andy reed knew and he also knew or
suspected that sean payton knew and
payton was ready to take mahomes at pick
number 11. so reed knew i got to get to
number 10 if i'm going to get patrick
mahomes he did he sat him for almost an
entire year last year he becomes the
nfl's next big thing generational talent
revealed itself and here he is in the
super bowl this year almost made it last
year didn't get a chance to even touch
the football in overtime in the afc
championship loss to the patriots this
year he gets there and the most
important player for either team i think
by far is patrick mahomes
and the chiefs would not be in this game
right now if they hadn't made that move
up to number 10 three years ago in the
draft to get patrick mahomes peter
i can't agree with you anymore and i
mean in in my opinion the key guy in
this one though mike is brett veach
um you know spending some time with andy
reid and veach
in the last three days uh there's no
question that veach
was the engine that drove the train to
go get patrick mahomes as reed told me
he had so much information on every team
in the draft and their interest he was a
real private investigator and that's why
they knew they had to get ahead of the
saints
yeah you know in hindsight he should
have been the first overall pick baker
mayfield has said that himself with all
due respect to the fact that baker
mayfield was the first overall pick of
the browns a year later he had said my
home should have been the first pick of
the browns in 2017 sorry miles garrett
but it should have been my homes the
fact that they they they all kept it
quiet it didn't leak out and it kept my
homes from shooting up to the top of the
board like so many guys tend to do it
was a great move by the chiefs and i
think the main reason why they're here
all right peter round two who do you
have
i got the chiefs hiring andy reid
you remember mike obviously
reid left philadelphia after a tragic
year you know his son died of a drug
overdose and the eagles uh you know just
really needed to make a change and so
they let go of andy reid and everybody
thought i mean everybody thought that
andy reid was going to take a year off
and quite honestly should have taken a
year off that's what football the
football world and and and most people
thought
but clark hunt sort of swooped in
and basically
found out from andy reid you know he
wanted to find out for himself
you know are you ready are you still
intent on coaching are you going to step
back for a while because of the family
tragedy
tammy reed was a big player in this uh
in this and tammy and andy reid both
agreed that
uh i i don't think i would be well
served by taking a year off
and sort of just
you know moping around
after the death of my son and so
i think getting andy reed
set the kansas city chiefs on the path
uh that they've you know that now
they've ended up in this super bowl
yeah absolutely and even though this is
their first super bowl trip under reed
they've been relevant every year they've
been a contending team every year and
now it feels like
they're going to contend as long as
patrick mahomes is around which will at
least take them beyond andy reid's
career however long he wants to coach
and that's the thing you know i
suggested maybe if he wins the super
bowl he walks off into the sunset really
why the hell would he you got patrick
mahomes you could build a dynasty in
kansas city why would you stop now peter
i hate to say mike mike he's only 61
years old you know and you look at
belichick coaching well into his 60s you
look at what tom coughlin was now andy
reid is probably not the the workout guy
that tom coughlin was he isn't
but i can tell you andy reid's not
retiring
he's not going off into the sunset he's
i don't know how many years he's got
left three what i i i don't i really
don't know but andy reid's gonna keep
coaching this team
all right next pick for me the 49ers
going four and 12 in 2018 fueled by the
torn acl suffered by jimmy garoppolo
against the chiefs in kansas city in
week three both kyle shanahan and
garoppolo talked last week peter about
how important being that bad last year
was to getting themselves in position to
lay the foundation for this year's team
nick bose at the top of round one guys
like debo samuel at the top of round two
i mean this has allowed this 49ers team
to really go next level and if you don't
finish four and 12 if you don't earn the
second overall pick you don't have nick
bosa and maybe you're not in this spot
because bosa has been phenomenal this
year and it gets back to that tanking
conversation we had last segment the
49ers tried to do it it just kind of
happened organically but it proves the
benefit of being bad one year
if you're bad in the right year where
you can get a truly transformational
player at the top of the draft you can
get good very very quickly
mike my next pick is going to also have
to do with the 49ers and it's a bit
arcane
so you're going to have to sort of
follow me and i have no idea how stats
is going to be able to form this in a
few words on his little tweet that he's
going to send out when everybody's going
to vote for you anyway
so
that is not going to be my concern but
it is the combination of jed york
basically saying okay kyle shanahan i
trust you i'll give you a six-year
contract and everybody in the nfl
laughing
at a six-year contract being given out
everybody except all the coaches who say
man that's good for us a six-year
contract
joe douglas with the new york jets hey
i'll take a six-year contract that's the
only way i'll come here and that has
kind of become the if we are
in the dregs of football society
then and you really want us to come and
save your franchise give us a six year
contract kyle shanahan got one john
lynch came got one and it forces
an owner to be patient so that if you're
10 and 22 or whatever they were after
their first two years nine and 23. i
forget
whatever you are after your first two
years you're not firing the coach unless
you robbed a bank you know you basically
are stuck with these guys absolute
minimum three to four years
that has provided john lynch and kyle
shanahan the freedom
and basically the long leash to build a
team the right way
the only caveat there and actually this
is a benefit to the 49ers organization
having shanahan under contract for three
more years after matt rule gets nearly
nine million a year from the panthers
shanahan's got to be thinking hey boy i
wish i'd signed a shorter contract i'd
like to get to free agency if a guy
who's never coached in the nfl before
he's getting 9 million a year and i
could maybe walk out the door and set my
price at 15 or 20 million a year but
you're right peter that provided a
stability that the 49ers desperately
needed at the time because they had gone
from jim harbaugh very acrimonious
mutual parting yeah right to jim tomsula
which was a mistake from the get-go to
chip kelly which was a mistake from the
get-go they needed to stabilize they
were becoming the browns
and now they've made the right hire they
got the right guy and it's working and
the browns just have to think how in the
hell did it happen for them and it can't
happen for us because the 49ers really
were in that same place and credit to
jed york for making the right hire
making the commitment basically tying
his hands
and and preventing him from having any
temptation to move on after a 4-12
season which maybe jimmy haslam would
have done if it was a brown's head coach
you're right they they we knew the hot
seat wasn't anywhere close because of
those contracts and now it all pays off
in a huge way so that's that's a great
choice all right for me
last pick 28-3
that to me
is one of the major factors fueling kyle
shanahan motivating kyle shanahan the
blame that he took for the play call
that he made on second and 11 with the
score 28 to 20 in super bowl 51. he
talked earlier this week about how he
learned from that and he'll never relax
no matter how big of a lead he has i
think that scar on his psyche from
losing in his last game with the falcons
went up 28-3 the hay was in the barn the
super bowl was one that's going to serve
the 49ers very well it has served them
well
and it's helped mature kyle shanahan
into one of the best coaches in the nfl
so the 49ers benefit from the misfortune
of the falcons because it makes him a
better coach it's helped position him
for this game and it's going to ensure
that if they build a lead against the
chiefs they're not going to go houston
texans and blow a 24-point lead they
know that they need to hold it and
nobody knows better than kyle shanahan
peter
the reason why that is so important in
my opinion mike is that it's all a part
of the kyle shanahan psyche
uh he learned from that he's learned
from everything and you know i'll never
forget
a long time ago this was sometime in the
90s when i was covering a broncos game
mike shanahan was the coach
and young kyle was at the facility one
day on a saturday saturday morning and i
mean i knew that was mike's kid but you
just you really don't have any idea you
know what he's soaking in or what's
happening and you know 100 coaches kids
have been at the facility on saturday
morning when it's just a you know
basically a walk-through it's a relaxing
time for your team putting the final bit
of hay in the barn and all that
but at that time kyle shanahan was
starting to grasp you know when most
kids say oh here's what i want to do i
want to go make music videos when i grow
up i mean kyle shanahan knew middle
school high school i want to be a coach
you know if i can't be a player i want
to be a coach and that's when he started
to soak it in and mike
that was a gigantic lesson that when you
lose a 25 point super bowl lead
everybody can say well
you know matt ryan should have done this
and and the defense should have done
that and they should have been able to
stop brady you have to look in the
mirror and you have to say
i made some play calls that were huge
mistakes down the stretch in that game
yeah and you know what as a player
something chris sims has said multiple
times recently shanahan was before his
time as a slot receiver that if he had
been coming out of college in the days
of wes welker and julian edelman he may
have had a better opportunity to make it
in the nfl uh than he did at the time
that uh he really had the skills to be a
great slot receiver so he could have
played and then coach but as it stands
40 years old one of the best coaches in
the nfl those are our picks for today's
draft we're going to take a quick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports